cómo
vamos
[Aplausos]
cuántos followers son muchos followers
cuántos seguidores se necesita para ser
considerado un influencers
para mí
mil seguidores sería tener muchísimos
seguidores porque no conozco a mil
personas
con tus números les gustaría tener en
sus redes sociales
10.000
50.000
cien mil bueno tienes un gran número no
pero que me dicen de 500 mil que están a
la mitad del millón un millón de
followers que harían con esa cantidad de
gente que lo sigue vayan pero digo no
hay que ser mediocres no siempre se
puede más
cristiano ronaldo tiene 158 millones de
followers es la persona más seguida en
instagram
que tanto nos importan los números en
una pantalla
es cierto que el valor de las personas
lo medimos por la cantidad de seguidores
que tienen
lo que es verdad es que hay un cierto
tipo de admiración hacia estas personas
porque aunque no sepamos bien lo que
hacen pues algo bueno deben detenernos
si tanta gente lo sigue
les voy a contar que hace unos meses
estaba en un bar con mis amigos y
llegaron otras personas a sentarse a la
mesa con nosotros
y estas personitas pues fueron un
poquito groseros conmigo no digamos que
me ignoraron durante un rato hasta que
mi amigo les pregunto que si sabían
quién era yo
ellos dijeron que no el hijo de amigos
debería seguir en instagram es muy
chistosa pues ellos se sintieron un poco
obligados sacaron su celular se metieron
a instagram no sé cómo te llamas
romina sangre
lo ven y michelle porque tienes una
palomita azul y a partir de ahí fueron
súper buena onda conmigo super lindos ya
está me invitaron un shot para que vean
para que vean
vivimos en un momento de la historia
donde la gente quiere ser famosa
haciendo que
quién sabe
pero asociamos popularidad en redes con
éxito y entonces vemos a estos
influencers digitales como si fueran lo
máximo no digo que quien no quiere sus
vidas
un día están en nueva york a los tres
días en tokio este desayunan siempre en
hoteles espectaculares todos les regalan
pues si no si no quiere esa vida
yo les voy a contar un poco de mi
experiencia en estos últimos cinco años
en el mundo digital
hola soy romina sacre
soy emprendedora
soy la creadora de romina midi de dog
love y todas esas cosas que alguna vez
me dijeron que eran mis defectos se
convirtieron en mis mejores aliados
soy muy intensa soy muy pasional no me
pocas callada
no me tomo la vida muy en serio y me
gusta mucho el humor
y a pesar de que yo estudié actuación en
nueva york' y yo pensé que iba a ser la
más famosa tipo salma hayek o más
ganadora del oscar la vida me llevó por
otros rumbos o
en el 2013 me invitaron a ser parte de
una página web
quiere hablar a las personas y a las
mujeres en específico de una forma más
real y más honesta
porque las mujeres queremos todo no
queremos ser las máximas en nuestro
trabajo pero también queremos vernos
guapas y así nació púrpura
y entonces lanzamos esta página con
expectativas en octubre del 2013 la
lanzamos y un mes después un post que
escribí que relataba las épocas de
acapulco en el 2000 y lo divertido que
era ir al antro de moda se volvió viral
lo leyeron 500.000 personas esa fue mi
bienvenida al mundo del internet y yo no
entendía lo que estaba pasando fue la
mejor forma en la que la gente se enteró
de la existencia de púrpura y este
proyecto al cual yo le tenía cero fe se
convirtió en mi trabajo de tiempo
completo y me di cuenta que lo que más
me gusta en la vida es comunicarme con
las personas y me gusta generar un
contenido divertido que sume y que el
aporte a los demás y la gente me
pregunta oye para cómo lo hiciste en
cinco años no mi respuesta es trabajar
muy duro pero encima tener muy claro el
por qué haces lo que haces todos los
días y que cada una de las cosas que se
publican en mis plataformas deben de
tener los siguientes tres valores
honestidad respeto y responsabilidad
y bueno
debemos siempre tener esto en mente
porque
porque cuando yo lance púrpura en los
tres años de vida llegó a los 11.2
millones de page views y saben qué
experiencia tenemos mis ex socios y yo
en el mundo digital pero lo que conectó
era la forma tan honesta en la que la
hablábamos en nuestra audiencia esa
forma tan neta y llegamos a
comercializar la página a los dos años
en un momento donde las marcas ni
siquiera volteaban a ver a digital pero
confiaban que nuestra comunicación era
muy neta que tenemos una comunidad que
nos hacía caso
y también han de decir oye pero si
también te iba con púrpura pues porque
ella nos sigue no porque también creo
que hay que ser muy honestos cuando un
proyecto ya no debe de seguir entonces
en el 2017 lancé mi propia plataforma y
fue un año bien difícil porque yo no
sabía si vivir bien si la gente lo iba a
aceptar engorde 8 kilos vive angustiada
me comí todas las uñas fue un momento
horrible pero decidí lanzar romina sacre
puntocom donde compartía mis momentos
más vulnerables y mis momentos digamos
que más difíciles y mi proceso personal
y eso fue lo que conectó con mi
audiencia aprendí que en el momento en
el que tú te muestras tan neta y te
quitas esa máscara y todo lo que tú
publicas viene desde adentro conecta
y fue porque llegó un punto en mi vida
en el que yo ya no podía hacer las cosas
de otra forma
me volví brutalmente honesta conmigo vi
todas esas cosas padrísimas que tenía y
esas otras cosas que necesitaban
muchísimo trabajo como mi control por
ejemplo
y por eso en el 2018 lance romina media
una plataforma que invita a la gente a
ser diferente a pensar distinto a que
cada una de las cosas que ellos vean
dentro de esta plataforma les sume de
alguna forma y bueno ser honesto viene
con un precio altísimo porque a la gente
tal vez le cagues sabes la gente tal vez
no le guste que seas tan honesta y por
eso quiero hablar del respeto
no podemos
dar lo que no somos
si yo no me respeto no voy a poder
respetar al otro
y es por eso que en mis plataformas y en
todas mis redes sociales promuevo
muchísimo el respeto pero sobre todo un
respeto hacia una misma y el respeto
hacia una misma es ponerte delante de la
fila no es un tema de egoístas y de
egoísmo sino de amor propio porque
vivimos en un momento donde el respeto
se perdió piense lo fácil que es mentar
la madre a alguien en el tráfico o
tachar a alguien de [ __ ] incluso
decirle [ __ ] estacionarse en un lugar
de silla de ruedas abro se arte a una
vieja en la calle
este ego y esta falta de conciencia
nos hace volvernos ciegos ante estas
acciones muy pequeñas que lo mejor no
creas que son tan graves no el estar
criticando a alguien el inventar un
chisme el compartir una foto de esa
señorita sin ropa
es gravísimo que estamos haciendo porque
se nos hace tan fácil es perder el
respeto a alguien
y bueno
cada acción
tiene una reacción y por eso vamos a
hablar de la responsabilidad
la responsabilidad va más allá de
cumplir
estoy bien responsable llegó a las siete
todos los días a mi clase a y soy bien
responsable no manejo borracho
la responsabilidad es asumir
tus pensamientos tus acciones
y tus palabras el doctor miguel ruiz que
es autor del libro los cuatro acuerdos
no sé si no lo ha leído es un gran libro
libro se lo recomiendo ampliamente dice
que hay que ser muy cuidadosos con
nuestras palabras porque una vez que las
lanzas al universo ya no hay vuelta
atrás y yo cuando cumplí treinta años me
pasó algo bien bonito
dejó de importarme lo que pensaban los
demás de mí
me valió cumplir las expectativas de
todos los demás
porque me cansé de no sentirme
suficiente
y utilice mi plataforma para dar un
punto de vista muy personal
y publiqué el 10 de mayo un post que se
llama no quiero ser mamá y no me da
miedo
llegó el 10 de mayo porque hay que
hablar del tema
y me daban muchísimos nervios porque yo
no sabía cuál iba a ser la respuesta de
la gente si bien no le tiraba tierra a
nadie pues no es común que una mujer
diga abiertamente que entre sus planes
de vida no está la maternidad y para mi
sorpresa conectó padrísimo no solamente
con las mamás que aplaudieron mi
honestidad sino las que no quieren ser
mamás y se sintieron identificadas
y por eso yo sé que tiene una
responsabilidad tremenda porque en el
momento que tú publicas algo ahí vienen
plasmadas tus opiniones tus puntos de
vista y porque a mí también me interesa
que la gente que me lee forme una
opinión esté de acuerdo no conmigo pero
que también los cuestione y los lleve un
poquito más allá
y ojo uno también es responsable de
quien sigue porque le echamos la culpa a
las redes sociales de que nos quitan el
tiempo y nos hacen sentir gordas feas
pobres solteras lo que sea
pero nosotros también decidimos a quien
seguir y si esa persona a la que tú
estás siguiendo te causa ansiedad o
angustia es momento de darle un solo
este es mi programa que ahora vemos
donde entrevistó
a gente que se ha salido de lo que se
supone que debe ser y se ha atrevido a
hacer ellos mismos porque cuesta
muchísimo trabajo no
angélica fuentes dice que hay que hacer
las cosas desde el corazón
y creo que lo más bonito y lo más
valioso de mi trabajo
es poder conectar con las personas y
darme cuenta que no importa que tan
distintos seamos estamos siempre en este
camino de ser mejores todos los días
y no se necesitan miles de seguidores ni
un canal de youtube con millones de
suscriptores para querer hacer de este
mundo un lugar mejor
es que estoy haciendo yo desde mi
trinchera para poder dar lo mejor que
puedo para compartir para vivir una vida
con honestidad con respeto y con
responsabilidad porque la vida no se
trata de un concurso de popularidad ni
de likes se trata de compartir se trata
de querer contagiar y se trata también
de dar ese efecto positivo aunque soy de
muy tono esquinca pero mira fíjate que
tiene muchas razones de señor y por
último les quiero contar que
fui a un restaurante aquí en la ciudad
de méxico y después de una comida
espectacular
se me acercó el chef y me dijo sabes
quién soy ya pesar de que su cara se me
hacía súper conocida le pidió una
disculpa porque no me sabía su nombre y
me dijo yo fui el que te pidió un vídeo
para su esposa
mi esposa estaba en el hospital estaba
muy grave de salud
y siempre se ríe con tu contenido
y solamente te quería dar las gracias
porque le hiciste el día le hiciste
sentir mejor
y creo que por ese motivo mi trabajo
vale toda la pena
estamos haciendo como personas
porque no creemos que nuestro ejemplo
puede influir en otro que estos son los
influencers no los que influyen en los
demás de forma positiva ese es el
verdadero valor que tenemos nosotros
como seres humanos
es lo mejor que le podemos dar a los
otros
desde mi plataforma siempre con
honestidad respeto y responsabilidad
y ustedes
qué tipo de influencia quieren ser
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]